so let's go through some of the negative
consequences
of not having local journalism and you
just cited a few
so i just wanted them to think about
this like some people
listening to this right now are like
okay my local paper is gone
no one's covering high school sports
crimea river who really cares
uh you know i can get everything i need
on facebook the internet blah blah blah
you know like they're like too much news
to read
like what are you saying like i i'm so
overwhelmed with the news i want less
news now
more news is i think like a reasonable
position that people take too
yeah so that's what a lot of people are
thinking so here's what we're going to
tell them elizabeth
why should they care about not having
a local paper in 300 plus communities
around the country
right now yeah 2 000 newspapers closed
since 2004.
um we should we should care because
first of all our government our local
government's going to be
more corrupt in the absence of local
news
like whether you're reading it or not
somebody being the watchdog
makes a big difference period i can
share an anecdote you probably have
dozens
but a colleague who's a city councilman
told me that they ran city council
meetings and a reporter showed up
and then the newspaper ran out of money
and the reporter no longer
was there and he said all of a sudden
things became very different
and not good different uh sort of sloppy
and unprofessional
and uh kind of corrupt different
so that that's a government kind of
corrupt is not really the bar we're
going for
for american government uh so number one
worst local government uh number two
a more polarized partisanship in our
country where we're
um subscribing to this like national
religious
uh approach to having our politics which
is basically
tearing us apart from our community so
there's studies that show
the absence of local news increases
polarization and decreases
people who vote across party lines and
this makes intuitive sense to everyone
because if you don't get any local news
then you're just going to be
tuning into fox or msnbc or wherever and
then
you just vote along party lines and
that's it uh and there's nothing really
to
balance that or adulterate it in any way
so one
more corruption two more polarization
which is not exactly what we need right
now america we don't need any more
polarization this is not a good
good thing uh number three
number three is um the more local news
we have the more civic engagement we
have and that's like
that's critical i mean we're you know
we're entering a period we're living
through a period that's going to have
generational consequences for that could
be look really dark
or i i hope look like communities coming
together
rolling up their sleeves and finding
real solutions
to the nightmare that we're living in
that bring people together and
you know more people vote more people
run for office
more people participate in school board
um activities
when there's local news and when you
don't know about it how the
hell are you going to participate in it
yes
people run for office less they vote
less they don't know what's going on
i gotta say it's harder to care about
something
if you feel like other people aren't
going to care or see it either
you know what i mean like like if you
see it in a town paper then all of a
sudden you're like ooh
school board elections ooh city council
elections or whatever it is
yeah um but but if it's just happening
in the dark then you're like i must not
be important
uh we're pretty simple that way that's
so
true like the tribal is the tribe thing
like we have
at our school board debates that we we
hold that wouldn't exist if we didn't
hold them
that chalkbeat holds um you know like
it's a cool event it's like a place to
be
it's a thing to do with your evening
that's really fun and
hundreds and hundreds of people come and
and we get students to co-moderate them
i mean you can make civic engagement fun
and i feel like we've never had a better
opportunity to do that than we have
right now in our country like ev every
single person is asking these questions
of themselves
i think like what is my police
department all about
you know what what i want people to
reflect on right now is that the
national climate is obviously
very dark and bleak um but then one
counter argument because americans are
programmed for counter arguments at this
point
would be like oh um it's okay because
communities will step
up things will be better in like your
town right you know like so what if dc
doesn't have its act together
like you know that the city council will
uh
pay attention to the most important
things um it's a very hard argument to
make if you don't have any local news
you don't have anyone actually covering
what's going on in city government
there are numbers that show that the
corruption argument actually has real
monetary costs where the cost of
municipal bonds goes up if you don't
have local news because then it's like
yeah whatever let's just like pay
whatever bond rate
uh maybe they'll they'll take a little
bit of back scratching
it's been like a boom time for
researchers who care about
local news and democracy because there's
so many natural experiments unfolding
over the last 15 years
given that some communities have managed
to hold on to some semblance of
people showing up to municipal meetings
and school board meetings and city
council meetings and
some just have zero zero people and so
those kind of studies
are like amazing and they wouldn't have
been
passable america the new land of natural
experiments
that could be our new building sorry
let's just see what happens if you have
none of it
um so so chalkbeat
um so cool uh helping fill the gap for
local education
uh reporting uh and then the american
journalism project tries to take it
another step which you co-founded
a little bit later and that's
championing
non-profit local journalism business
models in communities around the country
yeah exactly um so uh we
you know i i've seen the way that this
movie
could play out if we're lucky like we
when we when you say okay what's the
what's the math here how much money do
we need to spend that we're not
currently spending to do
yes let's hear the math cool news we
need
um it's it's between one and three
billion dollars a year
um that's very very low elizabeth i
don't believe your estimate it's too low
no you should believe my estimate um
oh my gosh you should believe my
estimate it's it's it's low enough to
that we can do it
first of all but it's it's grounded in
um good thinking like
we we don't need to recreate restaurant
coverage locally we don't need to
recreate classified ads
we don't need to recreate the weather
report but there's a
core civic function that for decades
um there's been like a tiny little group
of very well-meaning and
public policy analysts who are saying
okay what are the critical
information needs that do exist and how
can we size them
this is a fascinating convo so i guess
we're shifting uh in this direction
which is great because this is
where where my head's been anyway so if
you look at the
lost revenue among all newspapers
uh it's in the 20 billion dollar range
uh now you certainly don't need 20
billion to replace all this because of
what you just said like you're not
trying to recreate newspapers
like circa 1988 or something we like
read that horoscope uh so so it so it's
clearly
much lower than 20 billion but one to
three billion seems so
reasonable uh you know i feel like and
you're demonstrating how it can be done
because you're serving
a number of communities uh it sounds
like very efficiently
um so the american journalism project
has been
trying to fill that one to three billion
dollar gap
exactly so okay how do we fill it um
and as you say it's a reasonable number
that's the size of many
kind of public sectors that already
exist like
dance is a nearly one billion dollar
sector
public broadcasting a billion dollar
sector
it's it's a small amount of money um
really in the scope of things and we
have
more than enough philanthropy it's a
very very small price to pay for
functioning democracy and uh continued
civilization
yes um yes i think so too
and and i so like how do you pay it the
fastest way possible is the question
that has been
keeping me up at night and when trump
was elected
i like so many people was really called
to say okay
i'm concerned about our democracy in a
way that i wasn't concerned
a year ago and what am i gonna do about
that
and i thought about it and said okay i
need to
activate philanthropy in a bigger way
than i've done so far
what does that look like i mean and it's
pretty simple i think
it looks like activating great leaders
to build new institutions of the future
and activating philanthropy to support
them to do it as
at least the first mover um it doesn't
have to be only philanthropy
and and yes i know it's not the best
situation that we don't just have like
free independent
money growing on trees that allows
people to be totally pure
because that doesn't exist we have and
philanthropy is not perfect but it's the
best we've got
and so we've gotta we've gotta assemble
it we've gotta
deploy it to really smart causes and so
that's where
um the idea for the american journalism
project came from we
we are on a path to we're close to
raising 50 million dollars
um and then and we've been giving it
away as our first fund
um to promising social entrepreneurs in
the
local news space and and you know
organizations like chalkbeat
that are positioned to scale quickly
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yangspeeks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you